I think this burger is like half of my
face it is almost the size of my face
like a baby's face Hey Amica I'm here in
Hong Kong my hometown for a couple days
apparently the fanciest mcdonald's in
the world it's right here in the
background
it's called McDonald's NYX they say it's
amazing and it looks super gourmet so
I'm super excited let's go in and see
just how fancy McDonald's can get
[Music]
I am here to order a little bit of
everything at this fancy McDonald's
let's see how bougie we can get gonna
start with this bakery style 100% Angus
beef thick cut Sharla lettuce tomato
caramelized onion Big Mac sauce all that
good stuff
California blends shaved parmesan
roasted sesame sweet corn croutons
quinoa they have Queen or chicken this
salads gonna be amazing
[Music]
who knew you could spend this much money
at McDonald's I think we are pretty good
oh my cafe
maybe I'll get a nice flat a chocolate
sundae waffle cone
I'm angle Macklin I think that's all I
should get let's look at the total order
$274 let's do it we wait for the food to
come they just give me my salad and then
asked if I wanted the dessert served
after it's like being at a an actual
restaurant okay no problem thank you
just got the ice cappuccino and the ice
law say they look insanely good look at
this if you put this in a Starbucks cup
and you gave it to me I would have
thought I would Starbucks it's really
good I'm really surprised I think it's
like freshly ground coffee
oshi premium coffee beans McDonald's has
their own coffee beans that is insane
I'm gonna check this salad out and this
is what it looks like
[Music]
grilled chicken croutons the crab fish
Mayo tomatoes shaved parmesan you know
of couscous can I put this
sesame dressing on
[Music]
I really like it I'm normally a solid
person but this solid I would totally Oh
real freakin food the crayfish is really
good I thought would be like imitation
crab meat or something
no it's actual crazy
[Music]
Jeannie is amazing when you customize
your own salad at Whole Foods that's
what it tastes like everything is really
fresh you can pick what you like it's
amazing
stories is really good let me get
another bite I just got the burger it
looks so good
[Music]
that's a huge burger look at all those
layers McDonald's fries just stepped up
their game and we have actual
silverwares on a plastic it's metal like
you would see at an actual restaurant if
I told you this was from McDonald's you
would not believe we're not talking
normal patties this is like double the
thickness of normal patties let's go for
it
you can actually see the meat in there
big nerd sauce and truffle sauce
together mine below it is so good it's
so good who would have ever thought that
McDonald's sells a couple shots I think
it was a little bit skeptical but this
actually tastes really good I would
totally order this again well still
looks like an ice cream rise this is the
chocolate waffle cone the texture of
this ice cream is very much like their
normal saucer for the waffle cone
it's super buttery it is super nice I
got myself a matcha a parfait
vanilla ice cream on top and then I
think there's like chocolate fish the
matcha smells really good
[Music]
oh my god this
it blends together really really well I
can't believe that this from McDonald
mango bank run at McDonald's it's not
like absolutely amazing but it's not bad
I'm really impressed we go now that
we've had burgers and solids and coffees
and dessert I think this is the perfect
way to finish off a fancy McDonald's
meal here in Hong Kong
thank you McDonald's for showing me that
even fast food can be really fancy
[Music]
[Music]